this is eight news now well barely a
month ago the animal foundation was in a
critical space crisis in fact it joined
other operational problems that County
Commissioners directed The Shelter to
fix well now the foundation is headed
back to the county tomorrow to ask for
over a half million dollars in new
additional funding eight news now
reporter Ryan Matthey explains why they
believe it may fix their problems
Lori Huron executive director of Nevada
SPCA says even at capacity they're still
taking in over 2 000 Abandoned Dogs a
year these are organizations that have
animals in their their kitchens and
their bathrooms a surge in returns and
surrenders she contributes to inflation
and pandemic problems but she also
points to this organization the animal
shelter that receives nearly 2.5 million
each year in Clark County dollars when
they can't take in the pets people start
calling us and for each dog brought in
here she says it's the equivalent of 800
dollars and operational costs their
costs that are not covered by our local
government but the shelter here who is
government funded now asking for even
more without like a social service model
of actually talking to people it really
wasn't helping that much animal
foundation CEO Hillary gray acknowledges
the weeks-long wait to drop off stray
dogs partly came from the summer shift
to self-service online appointments now
at the direction of County Commissioners
she's returning Tuesday with an action
plan it involves setting up a call
center to reduce wait times for
non-emergency drop-offs reduce owner
surrender intakes and increase pet to
owner returns with the extra staff
needed it's an annual cost of nearly 600
thousand dollars so asking for a few
staff positions and especially to create
this call center that's going to make a
huge difference we think that's
something that everybody will benefit by
the current process is clearly
unacceptable and County Commissioners
like tick segerblum are skeptical but
hopeful of the proposed Solutions if
there were a couple hundred thousand
dollars and we can make the system work
to me that's a small price to pay
now commissioner Seger Bloom adds the
cost would need though to be shared with
the city of Las Vegas and North Las
Vegas in order for him to approve it
keep in mind the animal foundation is
the only shelter that receives
Government funding